I can only think of a couple people who
I think could beat Trump and I got a
name for you who
I don't like Baldwin if I ran I would
win you would I would absolutely win by
1000% him where are you where are you
you're busy with match my one more time
states or match I don't want to miss
summer with my kids that's one of my
stuff you could be where am I gonna miss
summer with my kid we're saying I'm
gonna be President I'm gonna take the
whole summer I'll be like listen
everybody I'm going to East Hampton to
relax yeah well why don't you run for
president as Howard and I have to go to
Nick and Joanie why don't you run for
president as Donald Trump that way
everyone will have everything I ran for
president I would win hands down I would
be cause you would be the funniest most
exciting what are you a crazy campaign
if you're the hope of the Democratic
Party I don't I'm not but people don't
I'm only saying that because people
don't people don't really have a sense
of who's gonna come is somebody greats
gonna come up I hope but the only reason
I say that is because I'd love to run
for that kind of position we just have
things be very common sense so you would
never do so many things this country
needs to do they're so obvious